and then we saw the movie it in the
hotel room which we had received a lot
of like Steve said it was amazing Gardo
said it was amazing so we were really
excited to watch the movie it just I'm
sorry it's not good
mhm and the reasons why it's not good is
because I didn't buy the premise I
didn't buy this little town it's this
little town a tiny little town we don't
know where it is I don't know I never
forgot what it was called it's a little
small town and there's one Jewish kid in
it and they have a synagogue in the
small town in the small town there's one
black kid and his grandfather lives
there and one clown it's like that's
that that was the minority demographic
those three people yeah of the of that
house so all white people one fat kid
yeah in fact yeah but that's he still
why he's why yeah yeah so they have you
know this clown that lives in a sewer
and he I don't know how you say that
clean in a sewer you didn't I thought it
started off really well in the beginning
like when you the first scene where he
gets his arm bit off and he's like
little kids trying to get away you're
like oh [ __ ] this is gonna be great
he's gonna be great but I think what
bothered Bobby the most was that all the
parents were so like irredeemable they
were just all awful parents that's what
you hated about it remember like what
yeah I I hate him I also hated the
Jewish kid he's like so like frightened
and kind of weak ish and scared
typically what well you love it little
kitty
he's a kid yeah yeah yeah I just hate
the fact when they've to betray Jewish
kids that way I want him to be strong
and you know I fell asleep so about 20
minutes in and I woke up ten minutes
before it ended
and so I have no real opinion about it
and also if this girl there's a girl
that's in this group of kids right
they're all great actors these kids
right
this girl's dad is like a rapist like
molester right and it's like I don't
want that in a movie it doesn't salt but
not only him then like there's a bully
kid his dad's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
the main kid his dad is unsympathetic
and doesn't there's just no connection
well another kid her mom is fat his mom
is a fat like overbearing you know it's
the dirt you know who does kids and
families great Spielberg you look at um
you look at Close Encounters of the
Third Kind you know the house is messy
but there still love in the house right
there still you know come on kids get
ready for bed you know they're still in
et you know we're more the pizza box and
they're in it the you know the the the
house is chaotic it's seen when I saw
that as a kid I thought that's well you
know that's we're not work hurryin but
that's I I felt oh my god I felt the
warmth of that house the bestest
stranger things I think like the parents
believe the kids and that makes me so
happy when like the whole community is
is rallying behind kids and they believe
what the kids are saying yeah it gives
me the warm fuzzies for sure
I believe my kids any day of the week
because when I told my dad I was
molested by a guy with Down syndrome and
Rehab he laughed in my face
he laughed right in my bed no you did
you did yeah he laughed
no he didn't yeah he did in my face just
brought that up left right in my [ __ ]
face and then I started laughs and then
my brother loved it my mom started
laughing that's how we deal with in my
in the Lee family with tragedy well that
gives me the warm fuzzies too I guess a
little bit joyous
by the comedy and everything yeah
[Music]